Young was so radical a thinker it's just
beyond belief like I've read a lot of
critics of you and I've always I've
always got a kick out of them because
the things they accuse young of are so
trivial compared to the things that
young actually did that it's like
accusing a a murderer of jaywalking like
because Young was unbelievably radical
like here's one of his ideas you know he
thought that it was necessary he
believed that psychotherapy could be
replaced by a supreme moral effort and
so the moral effort would be something
like aiming at the good and then trying
to integrate yourself around that and
that the the good at which you aimed
would be something approximating what
you would be like if you manifested your
full potential and that you have a
glimmering of what that full potential
was so that would be the potential
future you and he thought of that he
thought of people as four dimensional
entities especially essentially that
were stretched across time and that you
as a totality across time including your
potential manifested yourself also in
the here and now and that part of what
your potential manifested itself was
something like the voice of conscious
conscience or intuition
it's amazing idea it's an amazing idea
right because it's like what you could
be in the future beckons to you in the
present and helps you determine the
difference between good and evil
it's a mind-boggling idea and you know I
think that it's an idea you have to
contend with and then he went further
than that and this is this is also a
remarkable idea you know he was
interested in this symbolic
representation of Christ and I mean
psychologically speaking and he thought
of Christ as the representation of the
ideal potential human it's something
like that so it was a symbolic rip thats
what Christ was is a symbolic
representation of the ideal potential of
a human being and so for young there was
no difference between there was no
psychological difference between who you
could be in the future beckoning to you
and the prey in the present and
orienting yourself in relationship to
Christ
psychologically those were the same
thing and then so that's a pretty
mind-boggling idea like Siri
that's a mind-boggling idea you know
especially when you add the
psychological idea that the one of the
things that characterizes your ideal
future self is the ability to make
sacrifices right and the deeper the
sacrifice the better and then also to
recover from the sacrifice right so
that's the death and rebirth so the part
of you that's most essential to your
full flowering as a as a being is your
ability to let things go and then spring
back from that so to die in some sense
and to be reborn in the service of a
higher good and then well then the next
part of that is that the direction of
the world depends on you doing that so
not only your own life but your family's
life and and because we're networked so
intently together you know that the
whole panoply of human kind and maybe
the structure of the of the cosmos and
you know you might think well no but you
know it's not so simple it's not so
simple